hey guys listen welcome to the webinar
on healthy ketosis in intermittent
fasting okay now one thing I hate about
webinars is when they talk about all
this fluff at the beginning of the
webinar and so it takes forever to get
into the substance like the meat and
potatoes well maybe I shouldn't talk
about me and potatoes but I want to dive
right into the content right after I
introduce myself
okay for those of you that don't know me
my name is dr. Eric Berg I graduated 29
years ago as a chiropractor
I don't do chiropractic anymore I
specialize in nutrition keto and in a
minute fasting I had a clinic in
Northern Virginia for over 29 years it
worked on 45,000 different people so I
haven't had a chance to really work
one-on-one with massive amount of people
to figure things out and that's what I
do now is I share the results from the
clinic on YouTube and I do a lot of
videos and I do this full time I also
taught at Howard University as an
associate professor in the health
department so I taught nutrition there
also is the best-selling author from my
new one of my older books called the
seven principles of fat burning which
has been majorly upgraded to the new
body type guide which which I recommend
this is the one I recommend that you
read not the older version because
there's a lot of updates a lot of
updates okay probably a thousand hours
of work on updating that book I also
train over 2,500 doctors over the last
10 years and I certified them in my
techniques I also delivered over 4,900
seminars in my clinic around town and in
pretty much all the governmental
agencies in Washington DC presently have
over 2,500 YouTube videos and over 155
million views over a million subscribers
so my goal right now is to disseminate
the truth about health personally my
story real quick real quick I grew up in
the Midwest I was raised on typical diet
ain't a whole lot of sugar
I mean excessive amounts of sugar and
this went went on and on and on up until
I was probably my late 20s in fact I
don't think I even ever
aid a vegetable until I was 21 I hated
vegetables I didn't eat them
the only thing green that I consumed was
pistachio ice cream and lime green jello
okay so I had a lot of stuff my
grandmother was an amazing cook and she
would cook a lot of carbs a lot of cakes
a ton of junk food and I would consume
not just a little bit but a lot
this went on I got into sports wrestling
primarily wrestled through junior high
school and high school and college but
what happened I would go into the season
undefeated and then barely make it
through the end of the season because I
was so tired because my diet was so
terrible I didn't know about nutrition I
had zero data on nutrition like it was
really bad so I don't know how I
survived the season that I ended up just
scraping through so if you see some of
my pictures that I'm presenting you can
see me looking very tired and very weak
so if you've hurt went through a
wrestling practice right it's intense
but with all that fatigue I do not know
how I made it I also then went into the
military for about five years in
reserves and basically pushed myself
through basic training and again barely
made it through the PT test because the
combination of stress poor eating lack
of sleep I mean I had some serious blood
sugar issues back then I didn't know it
until it finally caught up with me in my
late twenties to the point where I had
almost like sand in my eyes that was
blood sugar issue dry eyes to the
extreme arthritis chronic fatigue
syndrome massive blood sugar mood
disorder issues insomnia I had a lot of
problems okay I mean a lot of problems
to the point where I became very
motivated to get well so I'd be driving
on the street to get help and see this
little building over here
oh the health house well let me go there
maybe they can help me come out with a
bunch of pills oh let me try this over
here this is a health food store let me
get some more vitamins
let me try this vitamin I was reaching
for straws trying everything I had a
warehouse of vitamins but I didn't know
what I was doing so it really didn't
help until I stumbled on some
information that was the right thing
they had to do with blood sugars and
insulin which then I started to change
my diet now I'll never forget this I
remember cutting out cereal for
breakfast and having more protein and I
just like oh my god I feel so good like
my head felt so good and I'm like wow
this is really good so I started to make
little changes more and more I went to a
healthcare practitioner that found my
liver is really bad so I started working
on that and then I come home and I tell
my wife honey I'm quitting the practice
I'm going into nutrition she goes what I
said yeah I no longer want to do you
know traditional chiropractic I'm gonna
do nutrition she goes you know know
anything about it I says well I'm gonna
learn so I started to get everything I
could flying around the country learned
doing postgraduate seminars getting
training and certifications but the real
knowledge came from working one-on-one
with so many people over the over the
years but I just had this intense
interest to study obsessively 24/7
weekends and I never stopped so I'm so
interested in the body and how it works
I pretty much relearned everything that
I learned from school because in school
they don't teach you how to apply it and
from that came up with some great things
I'm going to share with you okay so
here's the peers the problem the current
model of health care is that you have a
symptom and you treat it and then you
manage it and the symptom goes away and
you continue the medications and then
you just keep going okay so it's
basically managed care manage your
symptoms there's real little evaluation
there's basically just suppressing a
symptom and so all the while the health
really doesn't increase so what's
missing in health care is the health
part because what happens you don't
actually
lose weight and get healthy you have to
get healthy first before you lose weight
and getting healthy is not necessarily
just about putting nutrients in the body
that's part of it but it's all about
getting rid of stuff that you don't need
okay well we'll talk more about that as
we go through this but if you look
around the most common health problems
out there nowadays and I'm just gonna
list the most common ones stubborn belly
fat like so many people have that I mean
it's just everywhere so that's one thing
that is a health problem fatigue people
are tired they're tired mid-afternoon
like I was they are tired after they eat
and then we have problems sleeping they
don't wake up in the morning feel
refreshed
they lost that vitality they don't you
can't get the sleep they're excessively
thinking 24/7 when they're trying to
sleep they get up in the middle of night
they have sleep apnea they they have a
lot of sleep issues and then you have
all sorts of mood disorders anxiety
depression very common emotional
rollercoaster stuff
memory loss they go in a room they can't
quite remember why they went in there
their tolerance for stress is low people
get on their nerves easily I know that's
hard to believe right but it's a very
very common so these are the common
symptoms that most people have but then
it actually shifts to more and more
issues that related to blood sugars like
cravings for carbs can't go a long time
without eating your nation at night
cravings for chocolate and chips and
salt so this is this is what happens and
then down the road these problems
magnified so you get inflammatory
conditions you get memory issues
dementia you get a fatty liver you
eventually become a diabetic you have
problems with heart problems clogged
artery potential heart attack and stroke
but other than that you're doing pretty
good right
other than the high blood pressure and
the cholesterol you're doing fine so
what I want to talk about is cause and
effect if we take all of the conditions
out there that are
and if we look at the common thread that
goes amongst all these symptoms both
short-term and long-term there's one
thing that comes up that's so common and
that is insulin resistance insulin
resistance so I want to talk about that
because if you don't know about this I
would definitely pay attention because
this is the main culprit this is the
cause of all these issues and if you
understand it you can quickly rapidly
reverse it and improve your health way
way more than anything else
way more than taking a vitamin way more
than exercise so it's all based on this
one thing insulin resistance um what is
it
well most people know insulin is a
hormone that's made by the pancreas and
they know that it reduces blood sugars
but that's kind of where it stops
but insulin has a lot of other functions
too so but typically at this point I
just want to let you know it reduces
blood sugars so if you eat sugar or
carbs your blood sugar goes up insulin
kicks in there and it brings it down
okay so that's that's what insulin is
but what happens is the body doesn't
like too much insulin especially if
you're consuming too many carbs an
average person consumes about 30 but 28
to 31 teaspoons of sugar every single
day I know well normally we should only
have you know one teaspoon but we can
get that from protein and other foods we
don't need to take any sugar there's no
such thing as an essential carbohydrate
so what happens is as a protective
mechanism as a defense against the toxic
effect of insulin and sugar the body
starts to block this insulin starts to
resist it so what happens it goes into
the cell and then it's not received
properly so it's kind of like if you
talk to someone and they're just talking
too much and they won't shut up they
just go on and on you're gonna phase
them out but when you stop listening to
them they keep talking that
you talking more and more right so
that's what happens and within some
resistance when you when that insulin
too much communication goes in the cell
and it's toxic the body blocks it but
then there's no feedback to let the
pancreas know to turn off the insulin so
the pancreas makes more in more and more
insulin okay so so that's what happens
so an average person that as insulin
resistance has basically five to seven
times more insulin than a normal person
so this is not good so we have the
situation we have a lot of insulin but
it's not working in the body it's not a
good combination okay because one of the
purposes of insulin is to help fuel the
cell and if the cell is blocked and you
starve the cell of fuel it starts
craving things okay starts craving and
it can't do its work it becomes weak and
it creates a lot of other issues so what
the body does is it tends to recruit
sugar from other sources like stored
sugar in the liver for example so the
body will start using up that sugar okay
especially the brain the brain demands
like most of the sugar in the body it
needs a certain amount of sugar so in
the blood if there's not enough sugar
because there's a problem with insulin
because it's unavailable the brain
suffers first and that's why people have
a lot of cognitive issues they have two
things one is cognitive issues which is
memory concentration focus issues and
then they have actual memory going a
room they can't quite remember when they
went in there and then they have mood
disorders okay so their mood starts to
go down grouchy irritable angry anxiety
depression and even anything with the
head like headaches that's a blood sugar
thing it's a total blood sugar thing
it's insulin resistance that's what it
is now
in the cell the insula the what happens
is insulin lowers a sugar and what it
does it converts it into fat so this is
really important so if you've checked
out just check back in right now because
this point is vital insulin does it when
it lowers the sugar it puts the excess
into storage
so infant is all about storing fat it's
a fat storing hormone it's a dominant
fat storing hormone because in the
presence of a little bit of insulin
you're gonna be storing fat like crazy
okay so that's really what happens so
it's it stores sugar it uses it actually
uses the sugars fuel but it also stores
it as fat and cholesterol and
triglycerides so all the most of the
cholesterol in someone's body is coming
from the glucose and then also it
prevents the burning of fat so in the
presence of insulin
you're not going to burn fat so it
blocks that so you can't lose weight so
everyone walking around with a gut you
got too much insulin okay so lowers
blood sugars it's store sugar it makes
fat prevents fat burning and now it does
cup all the things it helps you absorb
protein amino acids so without that you
start having loss of muscle mass you
have problems with wasting of cartilage
and connective tissue and ligaments and
tendons problems and loss of discs and
your spine so you start shrinking
sagging skin right here
sagging belly skin this is inability to
build muscle when you workout it's
because the cell can't pull in protein
also insulin has a lot to do with
absorbing minerals specifically
potassium I mean think about if you
become do petition and potassium which
most people are because we need so much
we need like almost 5 grams of it that's
5,000 milligrams every single day that's
a lot we need that but
to get that you have to eat large
quantities of vegetables like seven to
ten cups no one does that so on top of
insulin resistance you become so
depleted of potassium you're gonna
notice leg cramps you're gonna notice
fatigue you're gonna notice arrhythmias
in the heart you're gonna notice an
inability to feel calm because potassium
is a physiological relax or a
tranquilizer it calmed things down
insulin also is like the key that
unlocks the door that allows you to
absorb and other nutrients to vitamins
as well
so you're basically your nutrient
deprived so it doesn't matter what
vitamins you take you can't pull it in
so insulin is really important very
important now here's what happens check
this out so we start with high insulin
right and then we go for many years as
your body develops insulin resistance
with normal blood sugars so because
insulin resistance is compensating for
this excess and trying to help you
regulate it and it pumps out more
insulin to keep the sugar down your
blood sugars stay normal so check this
out you have high levels of insulin that
then progress for years okay so you have
insulin resistance the body's trying to
compensate for that by producing more
insulin to drive in the message into the
cell and try to keep things going okay
but we have normal blood sugars normal
blood sugars for decades okay so now
eventually the cell loses its power and
its ability to compensate and now it's
for some reason stops putting out more
insulin can't compensate any more to
keep up the demand and now the sugars
start going up sugars go up and up and
that's when you get diabetes okay so
that's the mechanism but here's the
thing that doctors never ever ever test
fasting insulin because if they did they
would have caught this a long time ago
now in this process some people like
myself don't just go right to high sugar
they first go to low sugar it's called
hypoglycemia or low blood sugar and so I
just want to name off some of the
symptoms because if your adrenals are
involved or your liver is unhealthy then
you're going to experience more symptoms
with low blood sugars because the
adrenal in the liver helps to prevent
the sugars from dropping down to low
if the sugars get too low it starts
release seeing hormones like cortisol
the adrenal stress hormone and even
adrenaline and even hormones from the
liver to release a lot of storage sugar
it's caught basically dumps the sugar
from the liver to counter the low blood
sugar so if your liver or your dream
ills are weak then you're going to start
seeing a lot more symptoms with low
blood sugar because you don't have the
help from the adrenals to prevent low
blood sugar okay so hungry between meals
that's a common symptom definitely
craving for sweets nervous irritability
brain fog tremors shakiness fatigue
anxiety panic attacks sweating heart
palpitations confusion cold extremities
like your hands or your feet migraines
tinnitus schizophrenia forgetfulness
itching vaginal yeast infections
fainting insomnia crying spells
decreased libido and women sighing
frequently and yawning an increase heart
rate and there's others as well those
are all low blood sugar symptoms whereas
high blood sugar symptoms increased
thirst sleeping after meals increase
urination especially at night and the
volume of glucose because think about
your body's trying to dilute the sugar
as a mechanism to protect you so it
actually gets rid of the glucose through
peeing frequently so your body's trying
to help you and getting thirsty to get
to dilute the excess of sugar that's why
trouble concentrating weakness tingling
sensation high blood pressure because
the arteries get stiff restlessness
inflammation inflammatory conditions
anywhere frequent hunger that's why you
need to eat every hour and a half
dry mouth dry skin erectile disfunction
ear infections
kidney damage cardiovascular which we'll
get into peripheral neuropathy retinal
damage that's the I fatty liver stroke
heart attack aneurysm that's like a
ballooning out of the arteries because
the you start getting weakness with the
the wall of the vessels cataracts that's
the cloudiness on the lens so it's like
opaque so you can't quite see clearly
anymore
and the list goes on and on and on and
on okay so those are just some of the
symptoms with hyper glycaemia well
hyperinsulinemia which is high insulin
we just covered that but short term high
blood pressure sodium retention high
cholesterol high triglycerides so those
are all that's all the symptoms from
metabolic syndrome okay that's what
causes metabolic syndrome brain fog
polycystic ovarian syndrome decreased
concentration and then long term heart
attack thickened arteries caused by
blood pressure blood clots if it's in
the hardest heart attack if it's in the
brain it's a stroke Alzheimer's because
you get plaque in the brain stroke
dementia and the list goes on and on and
on so when you have high insulin or high
sugar you get sties in the eyes you get
redness underneath the eyelids a lot of
irritation it feels like there's a
foreign object in the eye that you have
to rub it it could be like feeling like
a sand I had that dry eyes and the
cataracts which is the kind of the
whiteness on the eye so what happens
with the cataract is you start seeing
cloudiness and then they have to do
surgery but you can be totally prevented
if you keep the insulin low so then you
have something called diet diabetic
retinopathy now if you think about on
the back part of the eye you have the
retina the retina is nerve tissue that
extends outside the brain okay so retina
is basically your brain outside your
brain in the eye okay so it's a visible
part of the inside of the eye but it's
part of the brain it connects to the
optic nerve that goes directly back into
your brain so what happens is
get damage from the high sugar with the
tiny micro blood vessels that feed the
nerves the retina okay and you start
getting floaters you start getting a
demon swelling and you start getting
stickiness and and starving the nerves
and eventually go blind that's what
that's the leading cause of blindness in
diabetics is diabetic retinopathy retina
means disease of the retina okay so you
get all these issues and it's very very
common and you start getting blurred
vision glaucoma is also affected by her
sugar where the pressure starts
increasing in the eye to the point where
it starts compressing all the inside
structures of the eye so you get damaged
with the lens the retina all these other
issues you get dry eyes I had that okay
and the tear ducts tend to dry up and
the eyes just become very brittle and
they tear in the rip and you get corneal
erosion yeah a lot of issues now in the
feet the bottom of the feet and the toes
and the fingertips you get something
called peripheral neuropathy okay which
is damaged it's again it's it's the
micro vascular damaged blood vessels
that supply the nerve so then the nerve
dies and so the first symptom is pins
and needles tingling burning pain then
it goes to numbness then it goes to
necrosis which is dead and dying tissue
and we call that gangrene and it starts
spreading with the toes so they chopped
off the toe and then the foot I mean
it's insane
completely unnecessary and by the way if
a person has enough nutrition in their
body and they're not deprived of
nutrients specifically the B vitamins
specifically b1 they're less likely to
get peripheral neuropathy by the way and
diabetic retinopathy
that's a side note so nutrition that
does have important part of it but the
carbs that people are eating are
depleting the nutrients okay now what's
happening to the eye and the feed is
happening in the artery
the inner lining of the made major
vessels to the heart especially the
coronary which comes from the word crown
because it's a it's like a right around
the heart what happens you start getting
damaged in the endothelial cells which
is the internal lining of the arteries
you start getting lesions or breakage in
that and those cells so what at that
point you're gonna get leaking the blood
so and your body is going to sense that
we need to do some healing so now comes
the cholesterol and the fibrin which is
the protein and then the calcium and the
white blood cells and you have
inflammatory condition to try to heal it
and that's what forms the plaques so
cholesterol is not the bad guy it's at
the crime scene but it didn't start the
problem it only is trying to help patch
the problem so another piece of
information that most people don't
understand and then you'd eventually get
a clot okay which is different than
plaque plaque is more hard then you can
have a soft plaque and then a clot that
can form if the clot goes up to the
brain you get a stroke if it if it gets
stuck in the heart you get a heart
attack here's a picture of a micro
hemorrhaging of the lining of the artery
in the brain you get you basically kill
off your brain cells and you have
atrophy of the brain your actual brain
shrinks yeah and it affects the
obstruction the brain called the
hippocampus which comes from the Latin
word which means seahorse because it
looks like a seahorse but when you
destroy the hippocampus you start
getting amnesia that's the symptom
memory loss okay
early signs of Alzheimer's Alzheimer's
is really diabetes type three now
let's talk about this because the liver
is really the hub of this whole insulin
resistance thing because what's
happening is a lot of this damage is
happening in the liver your liver is
trying to cope with this and all the
extra carbs are being converted to fat
around the liver first so that's the
first target that you're going to get
you're going to fill up the liver with
fat then it's going to turn into scar
tissue that cirrhosis which is gonna be
very inflamed so you can get inflamed
scar tissue ridden and fatty liver if
the person has belly fat they have a
fatty liver okay so now I want to
mention this before I get into the next
part and that is this normal blood
sugars when you go to the doctor or
they'll check your blood sugars it
should be between like eighty and a
hundred but it should be like better be
like between 80 and 90 milligrams per
deciliter and I want explain what that
means what that means something like a a
teaspoon of sugar per all of the blood
in the body so you have about a gallon
and a third of blood in your entire body
for an average person sounds a bit more
sometimes a little less but if you take
165 year old person gave about a gallon
and a third of blood so if you took one
teaspoon of sugar and mixed it all
through that that's what normal blood
sugar is but an average person consumes
a lot more than that up to 31 teaspoons
a day that's like in sane so that's
basically 31 two spoons too much yeah
but it's hidden as breads pasta cereal
crackers biscuits waffles pancakes
muffins so those juice
and alcohol so that's what happens it's
all hidden people say oh I don't need
sugar yeah but you're eating wheat and
breads and things like that so instant
resistance is a compensation to protect
you against the excess sugar if you
don't change your diet your body will
then block it from going in but then it
comes with the package and your buy
tries to help you only so long until
finally you can't do it anymore okay
so now I want to talk about something
very interesting
insulin resistance happens in themselves
but it can also happen and it does
happen in your fat cells think about
this if you have instant resistance in
your fat cells then what's going to
happen it's not going to let any more
fat in there anymore or at glucose it's
not going to convert glucose into fat
it's not going to let any more fat in
there because it's resisting it because
it's filled up so with insulin
resistance what the body is trying to do
is get all the sugar out of the body and
stick it into the fat cell but there's a
point where your fat cell gets it's like
a balloon it gets only so much where it
gets filled up then it spills over into
the organs into the liver around the
organs as in the gut it's called
visceral fat fat around the organs
that's the spillover because your cells
are saturated with fat it's like that
balloon is gonna pop it can't take
anymore fat you ever see that those
movies aren't like hoarders where they
in their house is just packed with stuff
same thing happening but in your body so
this picture like you have this garbage
that you you you never take out so you
stick the garbage and the sink and then
you stick it into the cabinet and then
you stick it into living room and in the
bedroom and then over time your entire
house becomes unlivable
because there's no more spaces this is
exactly what's happening when you see
someone with a belly
they have insulin resistance so to such
an extreme that the liver is filled with
fat if I ever had an ultrasound they
would see that around the organs is fat
and it's just sticking out through the
gut that is like one of the biggest
indicators that you have some
seriousness and resistance and your fat
cells are to the extreme so it's
dangerous because now the fats going to
spill over in the organs around the
organs that plug everything up ok so you
can see right here on the left side of
the screen normal fat cells and then the
large fat cells and you will always see
these large overinflated fats
with insulin resistance okay the name
for it is called hypertrophic out of a
sight okay you don't need to know that
but the point is that they just become
so big okay now at this point someone is
then going to lose control of the
insulin resistance and now if that is
max then the sugars are gonna start to
going up okay
why because all the fat around the organ
in the arteries in the liver and the
pancreas it's gonna block function so
things can't work anymore so you're
gonna have a gradual shutdown of your
organs that's why I diabetic is as a 22
times more likely increase of mortality
rates they're gonna die 22 times more
than normal healthy person because of
all these other complications that are
occurring but most people don't even see
the high sugar yet they get all these
symptoms because it's high insulin and
eventually they get the high sugar so
it's a wake up call
and then put on metformin which actually
improves insulin resistance without
usually correcting the diet so now
what's gonna happen is they're gonna
stabilize the blood sugar but they never
fix the real problem so the problem goes
on and the what do you think this sugar
is going it's again it's sticking around
the organ so the person gets worse and
worse and worse worse to the point where
the blood sugars aren't working anymore
even with glucophage or metformin and so
now they need insulin so a diabetic type
2 is now taking insulin and glucose is
at the same time god it's terrible
because the person already has too much
insulin so now we're going to actually
add more complications this is like
completely and utterly insane because
the person's going to get worse they're
going to start having vision issues
because the actual cause it's not
corrected and then you're going to
eventually have some serious side
effects and eventually die and the
doctors going to say well these are the
problems with the diabetic that's what
happens we just try to extend the life
well you actually shorten the life by
giving the person too
in Flint and then they give you a bag of
candy so they can compensate by it
because you don't want to go down too
low
completely in utter insanity okay all
right so now you know about that let's
talk about what we can do about this the
most powerful thing you need to
understand is what diabetes is and what
insulin resistance is it's basically too
many carbs in the systems too much sugar
in the body the body is toxic of sugar
and refined carbs that's what the
problem is okay it says too much insulin
so the insulin is responding to the
glucose from the diet and the carbs and
the hidden sugars so what we want to do
is we want to reduce to cut out the
carbs okay we want to cut down the carbs
so we want to apply a diet that has a
long-term health effect that can lower
the carbs so the one you want to do is
called a healthy keto healthy ketosis
now the difference between a healthy
keto diet in traditional keto is that
the healthy ketosis is something that I
am recommending as a tweak because it
adds a lot more vegetables into this
diet where by other types of ketosis
programs do not if you're dumping in
reversing this problem and trying to
extract all the fat from the fat cells
and around the organs it has to come out
through the liver if you don't have
enough vegetables to compensate and help
clear out this fat you could end up with
more of a fatty liver so by going on a
low-carb diet that's going to instantly
stop it from getting any worse like that
within a week it's not going to be
stopping from getting you worse that's
good but then we want to do is you want
to reverse it and start cleaning out all
the fat from the fat cells that's when
we do in a minute fasting why because in
a minute fasting is that it is not a
diet but a frequency of eating and not
eating here's the data that you might
not know when you
you trigger insulin so for the more
frequent eating the worse it gets the
snacks in between meals bad idea so the
body regardless of what you eat if
you're eating it'll spike insulin so we
want to lessen the frequency of eating
because that is going to take the
pressure and the stress off the system
and start utilizing this overwhelming
spilling off of fat that's going all
over around the organs so when you're
doing animal fasting and combined with
healthy ketosis you're basically using
the most two powerful things you can do
to extract all this fat out of the
system and actually reverse insulin
resistance to a point where your body
can start to fuel itself and absorb
nutrients then the nutrients will work
before they didn't okay so so we've got
to cut the carbs down now protein by the
way we don't want to do a high-protein
diet and this is the confusion with
ketosis people think it's a high protein
diet no it's not it's moderate protein
it's between three and five oh three to
six grams of protein per meal
that's moderate that's easy to do if you
have too much protein you'll spike
insulin yeah so we don't want to do
large quantities of protein now the only
food that does not trigger insulin to
any significant degree would be fat
which is fascinating because we've been
so fat phobic for years back in the 50s
there was two viewpoints one is that fat
caused coronary heart disease on the
other viewpoint was sugar caused
coronary heart disease as a primary
thing but apparently the fat model the
fat connection actually stuck and all
these years we've been thoroughly
indoctrinated and brainwashed to the
point where people actually are still
afraid of fat causing heart disease but
before in the 50s we didn't have that
beer okay now would you like to know
where that came from
would you like to know I'm gonna tell
you recently there was a some leaked
documents 300 pages between 1957 I think
in 1971 and in this in these documents
it was a dialogue going back and forth
between the sugar Research Foundation
and scientists and I have a summary of
this right here okay and I'm just going
to give you the gist of it this is what
happened this sugar Research Foundation
which is kind of a front group for the
sugar industry basically did research
and found they themselves did research
and found a huge connection between
consuming sucrose and causing heart
disease okay so they saw that so that's
not good right for sales so what they
did they had a plan of action a strategy
that was to two things one was to omit
their research data that sugar caused
this problem or increased the risk
suppress it actually ignore it don't
talk about it don't emphasize it and
then number two emphasize the fat
cholesterol heart disease connection
big-time so they hired researchers and
scientists they hired a guy by the name
of Frederick Starck and he was the main
leading expert in nutrition at Harvard
University School of Health Department
at the time so they Kellogg's and
several other companies including
tobacco company sugar sugar industry
paid him a million dollars back in I
think in 1965 okay and by the way over
the next twenty nine years
he's also paid 29 million dollars okay
basically they you get bought off and
and he basically
did those two things he D emphasized the
sugar connection and emphasized the fat
connection so that's really where this
whole thing came from the sugar industry
and they did the same thing in 1971 with
the dental cavities with the whole
dentist industry because they didn't
want to cut the sugar out of the diets
unfortunately in 1965 I was born every
single one of my teeth had filled cavity
so I wish that data had not been
suppressed and we could have I could
have grew up without all this extra
sugar
my parents didn't you know they just let
me eat pretty much whatever I wanted
being the Midwest because I didn't have
any symptoms I was a kid right I had
blood sugar problems when I was 11 years
old so that's where it all came from for
your information I also want to just
mention one little thing about insulin
insulin has been around for about two
billion years on this planet certain
mollusks fish single-cell organisms with
a nucleus aim snails used insulin as a
weapon it's called the feminists cone
snail for example would inject their
prey with insulin to drop the blood
sugars so they become stunned and kind
of paralyzed and kind of tired so then
they can take over so it's been a kind
of a mechanism in the animal kingdom
Kingdom for quite a while and then even
1927 the psychiatrist used something
called insulin shock therapy to
so-called cure people and they wouldn't
have large doses of injections with
insulin to drop the blood sugars to put
people in comas for several weeks some
people would have 50 to 60 comas before
the maximum benefits were achieved
they said this therapy jolted jolted
them out of their mental illness and I'm
not
kidding is this barbaric the problem is
it has a risk of death and brain damage
from prolonged coma it would actually
wake up fat crazy so at the time they
said the brain damage was actually
therapeutic improvements because it
showed a loss of tension and nervousness
and things like that completely insane
and then of course shortly after that
they replaced it with electric shock
therapy and that's medicine and it's
best completely insane and now they're
using drug therapy which by the way has
massive side effects and suicide so
anyway the number one disease that kills
most people is heart disease number two
is cancer by the way guess what cancer
lives on sugar so again if you want to
feed cancer just keep eating sugar and
then number three is three the third
cause of death is medical errors I call
out row genic disease physician cause
illness okay it's number three and then
we have the lower respiratory diseases
and an accidents and then strokes and in
Alzheimer's and diabetes influenza so
you can see that several of these coming
causes of death actually are originating
from high levels of insulin especially
the first two alright so now how do we
solve this problem what we want to do is
we want to implement keto and
intermittent fasting ki now what makes
Kido Kido and by the way
Kido is involved in a condition of fat
burning where your body is breaking fat
down into ketones to be used as an
alternative fuel okay ketones are much
cleaner than glucose so but we want to
go from sugar burning to fat burning
that's the goal and in the process of
adapting we basically need to build up
new cell cell machinery to actually run
in fat and glucose so your body can do
that the only way to do that is to drop
your carbs way down and then the body is
no choice but to start utilizing fat so
it adapts it takes like three days to
sometimes up to three four or five weeks
to fully adapt into ketosis now in the
process
your body needs more potassium and it
needs more B vitamins so we always
recommend nutritional yeast and a lot of
salads okay those two right there will
help you make the transition very
smoothly now I want to briefly talk
about insulin triggers sugar refined
grains okay like breads and pastas and
things like that
frequent eating excessive amounts of
protein when you combine protein with
carbs that will do it too fat with carbs
will do it too like a donut deep fried
carbohydrate vitamin D deficiency
potassium deficiency soy oil
it's GMO that can trigger it as well
artificial sweeteners trans fats
cortisol that's stress all those will
trigger high levels of insulin how to
lower insulin very simply lower the
carbs do intermittent fasting add
potassium from the diet of magnesium
from the vegetables omega-3 fats which
we're gonna recommend vitamin D from the
Sun magnesium from the vegetables and
you can also add trace minerals chromium
and zinc and even apple cider vinegar if
you want which will really help they put
it in some water put some lemon in there
sip it with a straw that will greatly
help your blood sugars now the type of
ketogenic diet that I'm gonna recommend
this would be if we look at calories 5%
of the total calories carbs net carbs so
you would take the total carb minus the
fiber to get the net carb okay the next
thing we recommend is 5% in calories of
vegetables now if we're doing 7 to 10
cups of vegetable per day why is it only
5% we're talking about calories and
vegetables don't do not have a lot of
calories okay they have a lot of volume
but not a lot of calories but we need
the salads we need the large quantities
of vegetables to do this right very
important and you'll feel so much better
when you do it okay then a 20% protein
which comes out to 3 to 6 ounces per
meal of course we're doing them and
fasting that's a whole different story
because we don't need to we can reduce
the amounts as we do through go through
this but there's no way you're going to
do one
at 2,000 calories that's a huge meal so
maybe into 1200 calories and as your
body doesn't have been fasting it does
not need the quantities of nutrients
because your body conserves things it
becomes very it kind of protects the
loss of nutrients and proteins
interesting so after the 20% protein
you're gonna do the rest fat okay we'll
talk more about that in a second so if
you were to get your 4700 milligram
dosage or requirement of potassium every
day you would have to consume like 10
bananas or 5 avocados every day well we
don't want to do a bananas because it's
too sweet so we want the large
vegetables we want the large salad okay
so but it's not hard if you do let's say
for example you do 3 meals and in each
meal is a small salad of 3 or 4 cups you
can easily hit your 10 cups a day but
when you do in a minute fasting you're
doing like two meals or one meal then
you need a little less maybe it's 7 cups
but it's not hard to do this so one of
those bags of lettuce that you get at
the grocery store it's usually about 7
or 8 ounces 1 ounce equals 1 cup ok so
you can think with that just look at the
ounces and that will tell you how many
cups like one of those plastic
containers of salad I like to get
organic like they come in 8 ounce or
sometimes they come in 20 ounce so just
realize that if it's 8 ounces that's 8
cups so the big problem that people have
even if they're eating healthy is that
they're eating too frequently they're
doing 3 meals plus snacks plus snacks at
night I'm guilty
in fact my left and my first book this
is what I recommended which was very
very not good because it kept me from
getting a hundred percent results and
other people too especially if they had
a slow metabolism so we don't want to do
that we want to start off with 3 meals
no snacks at all how do you do that well
at the meal you start with your salad
first then your protein and then you
want to add fat enough fat
you can go from one meal to the next
without being uncomfortable so that's
something you're gonna have to adjust
you know you can add brie cheese you can
add peanut butter avocado coconut oil a
little more butter you can add all these
things cream cheese anything like that
and then that's gonna actually allow you
to go from one meal to the next and then
that big salad with all the potassium
will also definitely help you too so
it'll be easy to do that if you make
these changes but you always need to do
healthy keep doses within a minute
fasting together they don't work
individually because if you're still
eating carbs a lot of carbs and you're
doing intimate fasting you'll never get
into ketosis so you're gonna basically
start stretching out the times you don't
eat and literally make it hell for
yourself because if you with blood
sugars trying to go intimate fasting
when you're starving it's gonna really
create a brain strain it's only when you
convert over to fat-burning where your
brain is happy and it's like you don't
get hungry and you feel focused I have
endurance all day long it's the best
thing for the brain but not if you're
eating carbs so three meals and then
what happens is the rule is that you
don't eat if you're not hungry
okay don't eat if you're not hungry in
the morning if you're not hungry don't
eat but what we want to do after you
comfortable three meals no snacks is
start pushing your breakfast further and
further towards lunch to the point where
you make it it's gone so you don't eat
in the morning you just have your first
meal at lunch now you might think you're
starving yourself but now your body when
you start doing it a man fasting it does
something really weird and interesting
the stress of that caused your body to
survive at a certain level where it
starts to recycle old damaged protein
structure parts of the cell and microbes
bacteria virus yeast fungus mold and
Candida it cleans that of the cell it
restructures everything it recycles it's
kind of becomes a self-cleaning oven
it's the ultimate
in anti-aging also when you in a minute
fast
you basically spike human growth hormone
by 1300 percent in women and up to 2,000
percent in men that's incredible you
don't need to buy the injections you can
just basically do this and start getting
younger I'm in about two weeks from now
I'll be 53 years old okay there's a lot
of I looked at my high school reunion
that I think it's actually the 30th
coming up or just past I was looking at
some of these people I'm like oh my god
they could be my grandparents so I would
never say that to them but the point is
that people are and their 50s are like
they're like they look old it's crazy so
we want to do 3 meals no snacks 2 meals
and if you want to take the next level
this is up to you you know play it by
ear if you have a stubborn metabolism if
you have soured issue and if you're a
diabetic and you have a lot of fat to
lose eventually go to one meal a day you
can totally do it with a lot of success
because I know a lot of my clients do
one meal a day and they're so healthy
and they're losing weight and they feel
euphoric because they're doing fun and
as soon as they ate all of a sudden oh
they're hungry an hour later because
they spiked the blood sugars so there's
a way to undo that so here I have just
an example so you can see if you're
doing three meals a day let's average it
say 1800 calories this is kind of an
example of what you can eat with the
proteins fats vegetables so you can see
each meal looks like this right here and
you can even pause this and kind of look
at this a little longer but you can see
if there's avocados for the fat there's
protein there's eggs
if salad and then there's a burger with
cheese and then there's some other foods
looks like there's some pork right here
with this other dish alright so that's
three meals and then we have two meals a
day where now we're going to actually
instead of keeping it at 1,800 calories
maybe you go down to 1,500 calories okay
we split it up have two bigger meals and
that's kind of what it would look like
okay and then down to one meal 1200
calories it's more quantity you can see
the amount of protein fat and vegetable
that's that you would eat just to give
you an example some people might
discourage you
especially the sugar sugar industry
which is going to continue to put out
that keto is the worst thing you can do
don't do a minute fasting and hurt your
thyroid it's rated the worst diet do the
- diet really so in other words consumes
60 percent of your diet carbohydrates
okay that makes sense I mean the
American Diabetes Association the
American Heart Association the American
Society and obesity all recommend large
quantities of carbohydrate and healthy
grains it's it's all political they get
funding from the food manufacturing and
the drug companies so for you to trust
them I mean that's illogical because how
can you trust someone that they're
they're basically a front group get paid
by that industry and sort of the
dieticians so here's what I recommend
you do you do the kid out in a minute
fasting see if it works for you which I
already know it will see how good you
feel lose the way and then do the - diet
do some of the diets that are
recommended by the American Heart
Association and see how you feel and
then you decide what is what's works for
you
chemo is very healthy because when you
do keto there could be some transitional
issues that you just have to understand
and go through and this is what I you
don't want to do this half way you want
to do it all flat out if you're gonna do
it do it 100% so that means learn about
it I recommend study how to do it before
you do it so that way you can do it
correctly because I can't tell you how
many people like oh I tried it and I'm
I'm getting a side effect well that's
because you didn't know you had to drink
lemon juice you know when you do this or
take B vitamins or nutritional yeast
because you can have in the transition
period you can have keto fatigue which
is really a B vitamin deficiency or
potassium you can have a little a gout
flare up it's only temporary that could
happen if you don't have lemon juice
Kito flu which you just need more
electrolytes that breath that means your
proteins too high hair loss it means
that your calories are too low
I mean constipation you're not consuming
enough vegetables bloating you're having
too much fat so there's all these little
things that they can you can tweak and
do it correct because this is about your
health this is your real long-term
health health insurance meanwhile my
health insurance is crazy it's like
thirty one hundred dollars a month and
there's a huge deductible what do I get
for that there's not that mean just the
catastrophe if something happened but
the point is that you have to take
health in your own hands the doctors are
not trained by it it's the whole system
is designed for managing your symptoms
not building up your health okay here's
what I recommend if you are serious
about doing this correctly and you don't
want to invest a lot in it okay what I
recommend is you I have a membership
site that basically gives you the
education step-by-step me taking you by
the hand what to do
answering every single question it's
quite extensive there's over 200 videos
in here you don't have to watch all of
them but it's something that you can
start learning about and it's an
organized way and get really good at
applying this information and take your
health to the next level okay and you
can put it on any mobile device and you
also get access to all of my recipes I
have a full-time chef that it makes keto
recipes and there are just a ton of
recipes that you can actually have to
get get access to I have some in my site
but you'll have access to all of them
there's quite a few kids meals keto for
kids
vegan keto meals bread alternatives and
a ton more also you get access to what's
called my meal maker which you can
design your own meals basically at a
press of a button pick the foods you
like press a button it generates a week
of meals for you and it has all the
recipes inside
so you can see the ingredients and you
have the meals because if you're doing a
program and you're not planning it out
for the week it might be more difficult
because by Wednesday and let's say
you're hungry and you might not go for
what you should because get something
quick and then you go off the program so
you really want to plan this thing out
so these are really really cool bonuses
okay
cost $39 a month okay or $18 a month for
a year commitment it's a prepay okay
what I want to tell you is that when you
do intermittent fasting and you're not
eating so frequent you're going to be
saving about three to five to six or
even seven hundred dollars a month on
food because you're not going to be
eating so frequently so that's going to
pay for itself and then some so really
this program is gonna cost you zero
because you're gonna save so much money
here but you're also going to gain your
health so it's a small amount of
investment to get all the knowledge but
I put a lot of work into creating this
membership site for you so you can learn
yourself I'm not interested in doing
what I did before or I basically
spoon-fed everyone and Gabe and actually
just how patients come in and doc fix me
what I'm interested in is the educated
person the people that are willing to be
educated and learn on themselves here's
the tools this is how you do it
fix yourself that's not meant to so if
you're interested in self-improvement
and you want to learn about it then this
program is right for you if you want
someone the spoon prove you and without
the knowledge then this program is not
for you at all there's a full 30-day
money-back guarantee if you're not
thrilled with this program you can just
get your money back okay I want you to
be happy so these are all the different
videos that you're going to watch to
make it really simple we have all the
different videos on barriers that might
come up with your body let's say you're
bored you're hungry or social situation
or you're not satisfied after you
or what if you get discouraged we have
every single handling for every single
problem because we've been through this
with so many people here's some amazing
recipes for alternative tasty
pleasurable foods almond fudge healthy
pizza almond pancakes and then body
problems I mean if you have constipation
or you can't sleep or you have bloating
or the knee pain and you can't exercise
these are all barriers so I'm gonna show
you how to fix all these things so you
can actually take your results way way
higher than you would ever dream
possible case studies from real people
just like you you can learn from these
people then we have the advanced
techniques which you'll get access to
after the 30 days it's like 31 days so
you can get a refund before that that's
not a problem you won't get access to
the advanced techniques the advanced
techniques go more into the body type
let's say you're more of a thyroid body
type or a dream about a type or delivery
body type there's certain additional
events things you can do to take your
results even further and that's all I'm
gonna say about that I'm gonna leave
that as a mystery and then there's some
additional bonus things that I don't
even tell you about that are really cool
charts and things like that okay so I
just want to personally thank you for
spending the time making it this far I
appreciate your attention I hope your
awareness now is to the point where you
see where the problem is and what you
need to focus on what you need to do I
wish you the best of success and I
cannot wait to read your personal
success story thank you